[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Collinsworth joining us and Chris
part of Sunday Night Football finished
the season as Prime Times number one
show for an unprecedented 12 consecutive
years great to talk to you Chris how
would you describe how would you
describe the atmosphere in Philadelphia
the atmosphere in Philadelphia I would
say electric when you play no when you
play with that fan base
um the same
um but it is it I I think it's the
hardest you know there there's a there's
an intensity that goes with Philadelphia
that I think is kind of unlike anything
else and even though they can be very
hard on their team you damn well better
not be right and you know they're
they're very familial in how they treat
their teams and they're gonna you know
they're gonna beat them up on talk radio
and they're gonna do all that stuff but
there's a real passion for it I I
actually it's one of my favorite places
to call a game
um because it's it's a big city but it
also it still loves sports and loves
football
um and that's not true everywhere you
know and there are some cities that you
go there and it's part of the fabric and
it's an important part but it's not like
you don't feel like it's all in
Philadelphia I always felt like they
were all in from the time I was a player
to a broadcast or whatever all right
give me the uh one thing you would
nitpick with the Eagles and one that you
would with the Chiefs
um I think the Eagles just the fact that
there haven't been there recently with
this group now certainly the Brandon
grahams and the Fletcher Cox's you know
those guys have but sort of the skill
position players haven't been there
haven't experienced that and the Super
Bowl is different it's just different
you know you know it when you walk out
there on the field and yeah you take a
hit and then you sort of settle into a
football game but at various points in
the game whether you're for me even
broadcasting the game you go and there's
110 million people watching this thing
right this is going to describe and and
my legacy for a lot of my lifetime and I
know because I lost two of them you know
so I understand that
um so I think that just the lack of
experience at the key positions in the
Super Bowl
um and for the Kansas City Chiefs how do
you get off the injuries I mean there's
a chance to me what Patrick Mahomes has
done this year and Andy Reid has been
simply remarkable I mean when you start
with the fact that Tyreek Hill wasn't
there from the beginning right I mean
this past year you know the year before
everybody went oh God we got it all
right Tyree kills gonna beat us over the
top Nicole Hardman all these different
guys so we're going to change defenses
we're going to go to this too deep shell
coverage we're going to keep everything
in front of us and it's going to be fine
so what happens Tyree kill moves on he
makes all the big money he makes 40
million dollars obviously a great player
did great in Miami this year uh the
whole thing but then what Andy Reid did
was all right let me go back and create
some an underneath passing game if
they're going to play a steep we're
going to do that now we've got Kelsey
we're gonna make a trade for Kadarius
Tony to add Juju Smith Shuster inside
still have the death deep threat with
NPS going over the top who played
greatness last one but they changed so I
think the adaptability of the Kansas
City Chiefs has been fantastic this year
but you can't go into a Super Bowl with
arguably the best team in all of
football being almost completely healthy
in Philadelphia they were the team with
the best record this year and you're
going to go in with three or four of
your receivers your quarterback limping
even Kelsey was some question with his
back whether or not and luxurious Snead
on the back end that was not talked
about very much he is there best
cornerback he does it all he goes in the
slot he blitzes he takes whoever the
other team's best is he's 6-1 he's got
some size so the matchup with AJ brown
maybe could be a little bit easier so
there's a lot of things that you are
going to go
I don't know until we get to game time
with Kansas City what my opinion of that
team's gonna be he's Chris Collinsworth
uh Sunday Night Football fritzy would
you give Chris the poll question today
most awkward quarterback situation in
the NFL heading into next season what do
you think that would be
um 49ers I don't think that that's not
very hard that's Green Bay you know it
to me it's they love Aaron
they feel like he gives them the best
chance of winning a Super Bowl no
question we did the game in Philadelphia
where Jordan love came in there and
looked great and you look great
um very similar to Aaron Rodgers Brett
Favre back in the day when they made
that transition literally very much like
Tom Brady there's still gas in the gas
tank for Aaron Rodgers and I you know
Aaron is is such an interesting guy you
know him as well as I do
you know if if he's not 100 wanted
you know I mean I can't tell you how
many times we've interviewed him and he
goes hey it's it's not my decision it's
the team's decision if they want me I'm
happy to play here I'd love to finish my
career and play here but if you know
financially and they've got another
quarterback and Jordan's a good player
and they want to move forward that's
their decision that's not my decision
and you know whether or not he would go
on and play somewhere else or just
retire a packer I'm not completely
certain of that one either I don't think
there's any animosity in this one you
know the the last time Brett Favre and
Aaron Rodgers and the team and that was
a little uncomfortable
this one doesn't feel as uncomfortable I
think it's really just sort of right
Green Bay Packers Ryan Voodoo currents
you know what do you guys want to do is
this is this where you want to go all in
for the next couple years and try and
win a Super Bowl with me or are you
ready to make the conversion and take
care of your salary cap go to the
younger quarterback uh because they've
got to make a decision on him pretty
soon too as far as what are we going to
do with his contract so uh but as far as
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable
but the Niners situation is it is
awkward because you know if Brock
Purdy's out for six months he's not
going to be ready probably for the start
of the Season you still have Trey Lance
but would you open the door to Tom Brady
coming in
and that's a hard one that that's
uncomfortable right I mean of course of
course you would
um
especially if I still
thought that Trey Lance was going to be
the guy ultimately and I think that's a
that's a a tougher question I don't know
where they stand on that they did get a
chance to see him uh to some extent
um this past year
um
but if you're it's unbelievable to watch
that team right with their third string
quarterback they made it to the NFC
Championship Game and in the NFC
championship game when they were down to
their fifth string quarterback they were
still relatively competitive when they
could probably only run three plays out
of their offensive player I mean it's an
amazing team it's an amazing coach in
Kyle Shanahan
and God would Tom Brady put him over the
top
probably and if worst case scenario came
about all he did was teach Trey Lance
how to be Tom Brady or as close as he
could be and teach him those skills
then that would be pretty cool too so if
Tom Brady wanted to come for a year
or two and play quarterback the worst
you come out of it is the rest of your
Young quarterback room
learns the most valuable lessons they
could possibly learn
tell me why Kellen Moore is now the
offensive coordinator with the Chargers
hello
I I I I wish I did I I don't know
um you can't look at what he's done in
Dallas and go he's done a bad job right
you just can't do it they were number
one offense a year ago I don't know what
the rankings were this year but they
were at least when Dak was in the game
they were one of if not the top offense
in football
um they got beat by the 49ers twice
49ers have the best defense in football
so you know one of the worst things that
can happen to you as a coach is who do
you play last
and unfortunately for Keller Moore he
played last San Francisco twice and lost
them both so I mean I get it that they
didn't look great on offense in those
two games but it was the San Francisco
49ers like who are you playing you know
so if they got beat
45-41 playing a bad defense in the
playoffs
does what he gets promoted to head coach
then I'm like you know so don't don't
give me the recency bias of what what's
the last thing that you saw and it's not
I don't think it's the way the Cowboys
operate
um to make those kind of rash decisions
but it I I don't know the answer to that
when I when I heard it unless he just
got offered a ton of money and you know
they already had a head coach that knew
how to call plays and hey that's why we
hired you in the first place was to call
the place it's time for you to I want to
know what you can do is the play caller
and we're going to make a decision based
on that and I don't know I mean you know
trying to get inside Jerry's head I I
that's a that's a dangerous ground right
there I don't know
and it might be an upgrade if you're
Kellen Moore you get away from this
drama you're never going to get credit
you're always going to get blame and now
you're going to work with Justin Herbert
um that doesn't seem like a bad Gig if
it's a fallback plan but I I look at it
and I could see a lot more positives
than negatives
I I agree with you for him and it
probably is that next step it would be
like Eric bienemy going to in a parallel
move to another place to be offensive
coordinator taking that Kansas City
offense really turning it on and it
looked like Kansas City the next year he
would be a head coach right there's no
question I think the fear is Patrick
Mahomes Andy Reed all those guys are so
good it doesn't matter who the offensive
coordinator is and so he's never going
to get the credit he deserves now if
Eric bienemy goes to Carolina and they
do the Patrick Mahomes offense and all
of a sudden it explodes there's no doubt
he's head coach next year if Kellen
Moore goes to the Chargers and they're
explosive and you go oh boy there's all
the stuff we saw in Dallas and they're
the number one two three four five
ranked offense then he's ready to be a
head coach so you know maybe it's him
maybe he wanted
situation is really troubling here Chris
this is five weeks in concussion
protocol
and
like I don't know what the team I mean
that's there's uncertainty there at that
position for them as they move forward
um what do you do if you're the
franchise with with Tua can you just
wait this out or have him take a gap
year where we'll bring in somebody
uh that one makes me really
uncomfortable you know and I said this
during one of our broadcasts this year
you know as a parent of two football
players in in our household they both
since moved on
um but if that were my child
and obviously he's a grown man he makes
his own decisions
um
but I would sit him down and I would
have I would put him in front of every
single doctor I could find and go look
this is what two three concussions
whatever it was this year
now I want you to tell me that just
playing football next year
is fine and it has no more chance of
getting a concussion than any other
player out there if you go no to that
then I don't want you playing if you say
yes to that then all right let me put
this scenario in front of you doctor
in the opening day game he gets a
concussion
now what are you telling me are you
telling me you need to sit out the
season
well if you're telling me that why
aren't you telling me that he should sit
out the season now instead of waiting
for the next can cut they're just there
are so many questions that I don't think
the Miami Dolphins given what they have
as a team because they're pretty good
you know they're pretty good can afford
to go into next year just standing Pat
and going you know it's like Patrick
Mahomes we just assume he's going to
play every game I I don't think they can
do that I think you made three Pro bowls
uh when you were with the Bengals does
that sound right
yes sir and I might have made more
friggin Miami Dolphins didn't have duper
and Clayton and Mourinho they were those
two spots were two out of four spots
were taken every year I was I was first
alternate several times but I'm not
bitter about it at all
um you know the uh being named of the
Pro Bowl that's always something you
wanted on your resume and and it spoke
to your greatness but uh don't know if
you realize Josh Allen's not going to
play in the Pro Bowl do you know who
took his spot in the Pro Bowl
oh I can't wait to hear this Tyler
Huntley
really yeah
yeah he uh he he had four starts this
year Chris
well you know all they're going to do is
play flag football yeah but it used to
mean something when you were wait you
know Hall of Fame credentials it'd be
like hey you know I if x number all Pros
I went to the Pro Bowl seven times you
know we mentioned those things Hall of
Fame time or you know when you're up for
the candidacy
and we played back then like I I'm so
glad I didn't have to announce one of
those Pro bowls where they started doing
whatever they were doing slow dancing
watching Pro Bowl in 10 years yeah I
mean I I but I did announce a few and I
played in them but we played I mean the
difference between the winning ten
thousand dollar check and the losing
five thousand dollar check had a lot to
do with how much you could drink during
the course of the week I mean there's
all the games being played you know
where the veterans would assign their
bill to the to the rookies room and you
know if you gave up your room number man
you it was over it was over all that
stuff
but my Lord the game is was unwatchable
I'm so glad they turned it into whatever
they turned it into who who took it way
too seriously when you were playing
um Don Shula actually I mean we were we
were in so I think it was Bill Walsh
coaching the other team my rookie year
and they were out there for 45 minutes
in shorts and running around in their
flip-flops and you know having a good
time we were two hours in Full Pass
three days
I I am not kidding you and at one time
one point Jack Lambert took off
everything I mean he was down to like
some itsy bitsy teeny weeny yellow polka
dot bikini underneath
took off everything sat on his helmet
arms crossed like he was going to kill
somebody if they didn't get out of there
pretty soon I mean it was just hilar but
we went I think we won the game ten to
seven or some low it was like a fist
fight out there for the Pro Bowl and I
was the 24th game that I had played that
year so I played in all four preseason
games
played 16 games played in three playoff
games including the Super Bowl and
played in the Pro Bowl I never played
more than 11 games in my maybe 12 in my
whole life I doubled that number in my
first year in the NFL we played 24 games
don't let the commissioner hear that
it'll be like yeah let's uh let's expand
the uh the regular season you know well
we're going to do that anyway no we're
we're gonna go we've already you know
set the uh 18 is the target day hey it's
great to talk to you congrats again on
another uh great season and uh thanks
for joining us Chris
You Gotta Dance that's Chris
Collinsworth